the atlas lions are back welcomed by a
roaring crowd
young and old waiting hours for the
chance to see
them honor them a team that has made
Moroccans proud
[Applause]
the proud of the national team and what
they have done this world cup in 2022 so
we're here to celebrate with them all
the things they've done for us and well
although we didn't want the final it's
very important for us to be to be proud
of what we made because we all made this
together and made history well yes we
made history this team showed what
Moroccans are capable of and they showed
the world how talented the Moroccan team
is feeling very happy alhamdulillah we
came from from from Holland just to just
to witness this it's a live achievement
It Feels Like Coming Home tears
Goosebumps everything if you can see the
people the the the the happiness that it
brought everything and uh yeah man we
love you Maghrib
watching from Casablanca is 73 year old
former Central defender of Morocco's
national team
anini abdulaziz played in the 1970 World
Cup in Mexico the team was made up of
amateurs abdulaziz worked as an engineer
and practiced with his teammates during
lunch breaks earning a few hundred
dollars a month to play for the national
team
we all wish to have been part of this
team they're so professional and
Youthful they clearly play for the love
of their country of their flag and of
their King
most of the players were born abroad in
our dual Nationals to receive a hero's
welcome from the country of origin from
where their families are from is not
just special it resonates for millions
of people
[Applause]
the success of the Moroccan team
has brought a sense of Bride and unity
for millions of Moroccans for the
diaspora for the app world for Africans
and this is the magic of Qatar 2022.
not the end but the beginning of a new
Journey for the Moroccan football team
in making history they now seem
Unstoppable carried by the support and
love of millions of people
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera Rabat Morocco